it turns out that we humans are
hard-wired to get a pleasure buzz from
uncertainty you might think that when
you gamble you only see the pleasure
circuit of the brain activated when you
win and that's not true so imagine if we
have you in a brain scanner and we've
got a little video roulette wheel up on
the screen and it spins and then the
ball falls in the roulette wheel slot
and you win or you lose well it turns
out that if we image your brain in that
interval that while the ball is spinning
on the roulette wheel you have
increasing activation of your pleasure
circuit you're not just getting pleasure
when you win you're actually getting a
pleasure buzz during that period of
uncertainty now I think that has a real
important implication for email text
messaging instant messaging and Twitter
so what happens you're walking down the
street your phone buzzes or beeps in
your pocket you pull it out you look on
your smartphone and you've got a message
and then you get to read it well the
bells in your pocket is signaling you're
going to get information pretty soon you
don't know what it is but you're going
to get it and I think if we had you in a
brain scanner during the time when
you're getting out out of your pocket
and you're opening up your phone you're
getting a look at we would see that same
slow mounting activation of your
pleasure circuitry that we see while the
ball is spinning on the roulette wheel
and then depending on what the message
is well that might be either pleasurable
or not pleasurable depending on the
content of the message but I think
uncertainty and our predisposition for
liking it is central to the addictive
pleasurable quality of modern electronic
messaging
you